Now developer tools can also be a really great help to
you during the code test refine routine.
You're able to test things on the fly and
see how it affects your page without actually changing the HTML and CSS files.
So for example with the header 1 here I can
easily change the font size to make it bigger or smaller.
I can change the font family say to Arial.
I can also change the background colors of things.
So, for example, say I might not have the hexadecimal color from the designer
but I just want to use the slider and find something that looks pretty close.
You can also click over to the Sources tab and see the code, in the same place.
And then also remember that you can reset any changes by just
clicking the Refresh button.
So go ahead and play around a bit with Dev Tools and
see what you can change, and then let me know.
Just how cool is it to play with Dev Tools?
Let me know on a scale from one to ten with one being
a total snooze fest and ten being totally awesome.
Personally, I hope you choose ten.